COVER IT HONESTLY.
WE PROMISE.
SEE YOU MONDAY.
>> Sean: WE BEGAN THIS NIGHT
WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT, WE ARE
WITNESSING WHAT WILL BE A
MASSIVE PARADIGM SHIFT IN THE
FUTURE OF DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION.
A BOLTING PRECEDENT IS BEING
SET, THE WORLD WILL ONCE AGAIN
BENEFIT GREATLY FROM AMERICA’S
LEADERSHIP.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, STATE
GOVERNMENTS, PRIVATE BUSINESSES,
TOP HOSPITALS ALL COMING
TOGETHER.
UNDER THE PRESIDENT’S LEADERSHIP
TO STEM THE TIDE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THE ANNOUNCEMENT CAME EARLIER
TODAY IN THE ROSE GARDEN, THE
PRESIDENT DECLARED A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY BRINGING UP, UP TO
$50 BILLION IN NEW FUNDING.
THAT WILL BE CRUCIAL IN A
GROUNDBREAKING PUBLIC-PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP DESIGNED TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH, THE WELL-BEING OF
THE AMERICAN FAMILY, OUR FAMILY.
THAT MEANS YOUR LOVED ONES,
EVERYBODY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO UNLEASH THE FULL POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, I AM
OFFICIALLY DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
TWO VERY BIG WORDS.
THE ACTION I AM TAKING WILL OPEN
UP ACCESS TO UP TO $50 BILLION.
WE AREN’T ANNOUNCING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO VASTLY INCREASE AND
ACCELERATE OUR CAPACITY TO TEST
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THOSE WHO
NEED A TEST CAN GET A TEST VERY
SAFELY, QUICKLY, AND
CONVENIENTLY.
WE HAVE BEEN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
PHARMACIES AND RETAILERS TO MAKE
DRIVE-THROUGH TEST AVAILABLE IN
THE CRITICAL LOCATIONS
IDENTIFIED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
>> Sean: WHAT HAPPENED TODAY,
GONE IS THE OLD WAY OF THINKING.
GOVERNMENT WALLS ITS SELF OFF,
TRIES TO SOLVE PROBLEMS ON ITS
OWN AND NOW THANKS TO A
DEALMAKER IN CHIEF,
ENTREPRENEUR, LIFELONG
BUSINESSMAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
THERE IS NOW A NEW WAY TO SOLVE
A CRISIS HAS BEEN DEVELOPED AND
IS UNFOLDING BEFORE OUR VERY
EYES.
YOU ARE WITNESSING HISTORY IN
THE MAKING, AND WITH THE HELP OF
THE MOST AMAZING COMPANIES IN
THIS COUNTRY, PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPANIES, THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS CREATED WHAT WILL BE THE
MOST ROBUST PLAN NEVER TRIED
BEFORE TO BATTLE THE CORONAVIRUS
ACROSS ALL 50 STATES.
TODAY, WE HEARD FROM
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SEVERAL
MAJOR COMPANIES INVOLVED.
AMERICA’S BIGGEST AND BEST
CORPORATIONS, BY THE WAY THEY
DESERVE TO BE PRAISED TONIGHT.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN, WALMART,
GOOGLE, WALGREENS, TARGET, CVS,
QUEST DIAGNOSTICS, SIGNIFY
HEALTH, LAB CORE ARE ALL PLAYING
A ROLE HERE.
HERE’S WHAT YOU NEED TO KNOW,
WITH THE HELP OF GOOGLE’S PARENT
COMPANY A BRAND-NEW WEBSITE IS
BEING DEVELOPED WHERE AMERICANS
CAN GO TO DETERMINE IF AND WHEN
AND WHERE THEY SHOULD GO TO TO
GET A TEST FOR CORONAVIRUS.
1700 GOOGLE PROFESSIONALS
WORKING ON THAT.
NEW DRIVE-THROUGH TEST SITES ARE
NOW IN THE WORKS, THIS WILL
DRASTICALLY REDUCE THE SPREAD OF
THIS VIRUS AND FUTURE VIRUSES.
HOSPITALS, FRANKLY, ARE IN MANY
CASES WHERE MANY PEOPLE BECOME
INFECTED.
ONE FULLY UP AND RUNNING, THIS
WILL ALSO TAKE MUCH NEEDED
PRESSURE OFF OF HOSPITALS AND
LEAVE BEDS OPEN TO THOSE THAT
ARE MOST IN NEED IN THE COMING
DAYS THEY WILL BE SETTING UP A
PARKING LOT OF BIG-BOX
RETAILERS LIKE TARGET,
WALMART AND OTHER BIG STORES.
THERE IS A RAPID NEW WAY TO TEST
FOR THE CORONAVIRUS, ACCORDING
TO OFFICIALS RESULTS FROM THE
NEW TEST KIT SHOULD TAKE AROUND
24 HOURS.
WITH JUST ONE STROKE OF A PEN,
ALL THE BUREAUCRACY, ALL THE
APPROVALS, IT HAPPENED IN HOURS.
THIS IS ONLY BUT ONE FACET THAT
THE PRESIDENT BROUGHT UP IN
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
THE AD ADMINISTRATION HAS
DEVELOPED SIMILAR RELATIONSHIPS
WITH HOSPITALS AND INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND UNIVERSITIES AND
BANKS ALL IN AN EFFORT TO KEEP
YOU SAFE AND COMBAT THIS
PANDEMIC AND GET OUR ECONOMY
BACK ON TRACK.
THIS IS, FRANKLY, AMERICA AT ITS
BEST.
THESE ARE THE DOCTORS, THE
MEDICAL RESEARCHERS, THE
SCIENTISTS, THE ENTREPRENEURS
RISING TO THE OCCASION AS GREAT
PATRIOTS IN A CRISIS.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE I HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT FOR WEEKS.
I PUT THE MOST FAITH IN THEM.
NONE OF THESE COMPANIES HAD TO
PARTNER WITH THE ADMINISTRATION,
THEY DIDN’T HAVE TO DO IT.
THEY DID IT BECAUSE THEY LOVE
THIS COUNTRY, THEY CARE ABOUT
THEIR FELLOW AMERICANS, AND THEY
ARE COMMITTED TO SAVING LIVES.
FRANKLY, WHAT WE SAW TODAY CAN
ONLY HAPPEN IN THIS GREAT
COUNTRY OF AMERICA.
THIS IS FREE-MARKET CAPITALISM
AT ITS BEST.
HOW MANY OF THESE COMPANIES, BY
THE WAY, HAVE YOU HEARD
DEMONIZED OVER THE YEARS?
OH, BIG PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES.
WHILE BACK.
MAYBE THEY DESERVE A PAT ON THE
BACK TODAY, MADE POSSIBLE BY THE
PRESIDENT LEAVING THE WAY.
WE ALL NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
ALL OF THIS DID NOT HAPPEN IN
ONE DAY.
HE DID NOT HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
AS ONE OFFICIAL PUT IT, THIS HAS
BEEN IN THE WORKS BEHIND THE BEH
SCENES FOR QUITE SOME TIME
OUTSIDE THE VIEW OF THE MEDIA
MOB AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
THERE WAS NO GUARANTEE THIS WILL
ALL COME TOGETHER THE WAY IT
HAS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I UNDERSTAND A LOT OF THIS
ACTION OVER THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS WAS INVISIBLE TO THE PRESS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT THIS INTENSE EFFORT HAS NOT
ONLY RESULTED IN INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS, BUT IN AUTOMATED,
HIGH-FREQUENCY SYSTEM BRINGING
THE ABILITY OF THESE ALREADY
CORONAVIRUS TESTING AT
UNPRECEDENTED SPEED.
>> Sean: ULTIMATELY, ALL OF
THIS WORK COVERS THREE VERY
IMPORTANT AREAS.
TESTING, TREATMENT, ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
IS WELL UNDERWAY.
FOR MORE CONTEXT, LET’S GO BACK
TO THE TIMELINE.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
DECEMBER 30TH, THE W.H.O.
DISCOVER AN UNKNOWN VIRUS WITH
PNEUMONIA LIKE SYMPTOMS THAT WAS
FIRST OBSERVED IN THE WUHAN
PROVINCE AREA OF CHINA.
JANUARY 7TH, THE CORONAVIRUS WAS
FIRST IDENTIFIED.
THAT IS THIS YEAR.
BY JANUARY 31ST, 3 WEEKS LATER
THE PRESIDENT COMP
ADMINISTRATION DECLARED A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
AMERICANS ABROAD WERE THEN
SUBJECT TO MANDATORY QUARANTINES
QUARANTINES, ON FEBRUARY 2ND THE
PRESIDENT ORDERED A TEMPORARY
TRAVEL BAN FOR ALL NON-U.S.
CITIZENS WHO RECENTLY VISITED
CHINA.
IN THE DAYS THAT FOLLOWED, HE
FORMED A TOXIC FORCE FILLED WITH
THE TOP SCIENTIFIC MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN THE COUNTRY
LED BY THE VICE PRESIDENT.
FEBRUARY 29TH, THAT TRAVEL BAN
WAS EXTENDED TO IRAN ON THE SAME
DAY THEY DEPARTMENT ISSUED NEWS
TRAVEL RESTRICTION’S TO AND
SOUTH KOREA.
MARCH 2ND, PRESIDENT TRUMP MET
WITH PHARMACEUTICAL EXECUTIVES.
THESE MEETINGS NOW WILL COME
INTO A BROADER PICTURE.
MARCH 3RD, CDC WAS ORDERED TO
LIFT ALL RESTRICTIONS ON
TESTING.
MARCH 6TH, HE SIGNED IT AND A
$.3 BILLION EMERGENCY SPENDING
PACKAGE INTO LAW.
ON MARCH THE 10TH, THE PRESIDENT
MEANT WITH INSURANCE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES.
THEY AGREED TO WAIVE CO-PAYS FOR
CORONA RELATED TREATMENT.
ON MARCH 11TH, HE MET WITH
BANKING AND FOOD BUSINESS
EXECUTIVES TO DISCUSS ECONOMIC
RELIEF FOR THOSE BUSINESSES AND
HOURLY WORKERS.
ON THAT SAME DAY, HE EXTENDED
THE TRAVEL BAN TO ALL OF
CONTINENTAL EUROPE.
THESE TRAVEL BAN’S WERE
CRITICAL.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT PREVENTED MANY OTHER
AMERICANS FROM GETTING INFECTED
OR CONTRACTING THIS VIRUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR AGGRESSIVE CONTAINMENT
STRATEGY HAS BEEN STARTED EARLY
ENOUGH TO AVOID THAT PEAK?
>> AS I MENTIONED, THERE WERE
TWO COMPONENTS OF THAT.
PREVENTING AND MITIGATION.
CLEARLY, EARLY ON WE MADE A
TRAVEL BAN ON CHINA.
THAT WAS A VERY SMART MOVE, WHAT
THAT DID WAS PREVENT THE MAJOR
INFLUX FROM CHINA.
TODAY, THE NEW CHINA IS EUROPE.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, BREAKING
JUST MOMENTS AGO PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THE RELIEF PACKAGE.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT COMING
UP.
DR. FAUCI IS EXACTLY RIGHT, WILL
ANYONE IN THE MEDIA MOB, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAVE THEY GIVEN
THE PRESIDENT ANY CREDIT FOR
ANYTHING HE HAS DONE?
NOT ONE THING.
IN FEBRUARY, THERE HE WAS,
QUID PRO QUO JOE AND OTHER TOP
DEMOCRATS.
THE PRESIDENT IS CALLED
HYSTERICAL AND XENOPHOBIC.
NEITHER BIDEN NOR BERNIE SANDERS
WOULD HAVE OTHER ENACTED A BAN,
THEY WERE BRAGGING ABOUT IT
STILL TODAY.
OLD-SCHOOL, OLD MODEL REGRETS.
FOR MORE PERSPECTIVE, LET’S TAKE
A LOOK AT THE H1N1 PANDEMIC.
A SWINE FLU, 2009-2010.
THE OBAMA AND BIDEN YEARS.
THIS FAST SPREADING PANDEMIC
WORLDWIDE, PARTICULARLY DEADLY
TO CHILDREN ON MY CORONA WHICH
IS MORE DEADLY TO OLDER PEOPLE.
IN APRIL 2009, OBAMA AND BIDEN
YEARS.
A FEW DAYS AFTER THE PANDEMIC
WAS IN THE U.S., OBAMA’S HHS
SECRETARY DECLARED A HEALTH
EMERGENCY FREEING UP SOME MONEY.
I WILL GIVE CREDIT, THAT WAS A
GOOD MOVE.
BY OCTOBER, MORE THAN 20,000
AMERICANS HAD BEEN HOSPITALIZED
AND MORE THAN 1,000 AMERICAN
CITIZENS WERE DEAD.
1,000.
AND ONLY THEN, SIX MONTHS LATER,
DID THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA FINALLY
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THAT YEAR, THE CDC ESTIMATED
60.8 MILLION AMERICANS WERE
INFECTED, WHICH ULTIMATELY
RESULTED IN OVER 274,000
AMERICANS BEING HOSPITALIZED,
AND NEARLY 13,000 AMERICANS IN A
ONE YEAR PERIOD DIED.
WORLDWIDE, ABOUT 575,000 PEOPLE
DIED IN 2009 FROM SWINE FLU,
H1N1.
THE OBAMA-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
OR AS JOE SAYS THE OBIDEN-BAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WERE NO QUARANTINES, THEY
WEREN’T QUICK TO DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY.
1,000 AMERICANS WERE DEAD.
OTHERS WERE INFECTED.
NOW THE MEDIA MOB, HOW DID THEY
REACT BACK THEM?
DO YOU THINK THEY WERE GOING AS
HARD AS THEY ARE AGAINST OBAMA
AND BIDEN AS THEY HAVE BEEN
GOING AFTER DRUM?
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW CORRUPT
THE MEDIA MOB IN THIS COUNTRY
IS, YOU SHOULD BE DISGUSTED BY
WHAT I AM ABOUT TO SHOW YOU.
THIS WAS AFTER 1,000 AMERICANS
WERE DEAD.
TENS OF THOUSANDS HAD CONTRACTED
THE DISEASE.
THEN HE DECIDES TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
GREAT TIMING.
NOW LET’S WATCH THE MEDIA
COVERAGE.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT THIS,
SOMETHING IS CONCERNING A WHOLE
LOT OF PEOPLE THESE DAYS.
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA DECLARING
THE SWINE FLU OUTBREAK A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, SHOULD THERE
BE A WORSE CASE SCENARIO?
SPEAK UP IT IS THAT THEY WERE.
>> MORE THAN 1,000 PEOPLE IN THE
U.S. HAVE DIED, 90 IN THE LAST
WEEK.
THERE WOULD BE 100 DOSES OF
VACCINE BY NOW, BUT AS OF THIS
WEEKEND 11 MILLION WERE
AVAILABLE.
WHEN WE HEAR EMERGENCY, ALARM
BELLS START TO GO OFF.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THIS
DECLARATION MEAN?
>> PEOPLE SHOULDN’T PANIC WHEN
THEY HEAR THIS.
>> HEALTH OFFICIALS BATTLING THE
H1N1 FLU VIRUS THIS WEEKEND HAVE
RECEIVED TWO BOOSTER SHOTS OF
THEIR OWN.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS DECLARED
IT A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
>> Laura: NOTICED A SLIGHT
DIFFERENCE IN COVERAGE?
THAT IS HOW CORRUPT THE MEDIA
MOB IN THIS COUNTRY HAS BECOME
IN TEN SHORT YEARS.
THAT IS DISTURBING.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE AND WHAT
THEY ARE CURRENTLY DOING IS
HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
THIS DEFINES THEM.
IF YOU EVER HAD ANY DOUBT THAT
THEY HAVE AN AGENDA, WELL, THAT
PROVES OUR CASE.
NEVER BEFORE HAS THERE BEEN THIS
UNHOLY CORRUPT ALLIANCE EXISTING
BETWEEN THE MOB OF THE MEDIA AND
THE ONE PARTY THEY LOVE WITH
THEIR AGENDA ONLY.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
LYING HOUR AFTER HOUR, DAY AFTER
DAY, WEEK AFTER WEEK, MONTH
AFTER MONTH NOW.
FOR OVER THREE YEARS.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, UKRAINE,
UKRAINE, IMPEACH, AND BEACH.
CORONA, CORONA.
THAT IS HOW DISGUSTINGLY CORRUPT
THEY ARE, TO THE COURT.
IT IS REPULSIVE.
ANYBODY THAT WATCHES THAT VIDEO,
A THOUSAND AMERICANS DEAD NO
EMERGENCY.
IT’S LIKE NOTHING HAD HAPPENED.
MEANWHILE, PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKES
UNPRECEDENTED ACTION WITHIN
THREE WEEKS TRAVEL BAN’S,
QUARANTINES.
WHAT DOES HE GET?
CRITICISM.
YOU LISTEN ONLY TO THE MOB OF
THE MEDIA YOU MIGHT THINK THAT
THE PRESIDENT MAY BE BECAUSE THE
VIRUS.
YOU WOULD BEGIN TO THINK THAT
THEY PROBABLY COOKED IT UP IN A
LAB SOMEWHERE TO DESTROY IT THE
COUNTRY WITH PRUDENT AND RUSSIA
AND UKRAINIAN MAD SCIENTIST.
THAT IS A LEVEL OF HYSTERIA AND
LYING THAT HAS GONE ON FOR THREE
YEARS.
THIS ALLIANCE IS HURTING THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE NOT SERVING WE THE
PEOPLE IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
MATTER, OR FORM.
THEY ARE ADVANCING A POLITICAL
AGENDA.
JOURNALISM I DECLARED IN 2007 IS
DEAD, IT IS DEAD, IT IS DONE, IT
IS BURIED.
IT HAS NOW BECOME DISGRACEFUL
STATE RUN LIBERAL RADICAL
EXTREME SOCIALIST TV.
THAT IS WHO THEY ARE.
YOU WOULD THINK THE WORLD IS
COMING TO AN END.
THIS VIRUS IS SERIOUS, WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU THAT FROM DAY
ONE.
WE NEED TO TAKE THE FLU
SERIOUSLY, WE NEED TO TAKE
CANCER SERIOUSLY, THIS VIRUS
SERIOUSLY.
OF COURSE, WE ALL NEED TO
PREPARE ACCORDINGLY.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS IS NOT PIE
IN THE SKY TONIGHT.
THIS WILL BE INNOVATIVE, THIS
WILL BE ALLOWING FUTURE
PRESIDENTS TO HAVE TRAVEL BAN’S
A LOT EASIER.
THIS WILL ALLOW THIS TIME OF
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE TOP
COMPANIES IN THIS COUNTRY TO
WORK HAND-IN-HAND WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT TO KEEP US SAFE.
BUT YOU DO NEED TO UNDERSTAND,
WE WILL, THIS IS A FACT THERE
ARE GOING TO BE DRAMATIC
INCREASES IN THE WEEKS AHEAD OF
THE NUMBER OF AMERICANS WHO TEST
POSITIVE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HYPED THAT UP,
I GUARANTEE IT.
THAT IS WHAT THE MOB DOES, AND
THEY WILL BLAME DONALD TRUMP
EVERY SECOND.
THEY CAN’T ACKNOWLEDGE A SINGLE
GOOD THING THIS PRESIDENT HAS
DONE.
THEY ARE AGAINST TRAVEL BAN’S,
AGAINST THE QUARANTINES, THAT
ALONE SAVED COUNTLESS THOUSANDS
OF AMERICANS FROM CONTRACTING
THE VIRUS.
THAT ONE DECISION LITERALLY
SAVED THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
FROM CONTRACTING THIS DISEASE.
RACIST, XENOPHOBIC.
WE EXPECT THAT AT SOME POINT,
FOUR TO SIX WEEKS ACCORDING TO
ALL THE EXPERTS, HOPEFULLY MIKE
IN CHINA THERE WILL BE A
LEVELING OFF.
THAT IS WHERE HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY A DRAMATIC
DECREASE AND REDUCTION IN NEW
CASES.
AND HOPEFULLY, THEN BACK TO
NORMAL LIFE.
IF YOU ARE GENERALLY A HEALTHY
PERSON, UNDER THE AGE OF 80 AND
YOU DON’T HAVE UNDERLYING HEALTH
ISSUES OR A COMPROMISED IMMUNE
SYSTEM OR ARE GETTING
CHEMOTHERAPY OR AUTOIMMUNE
PROBLEMS OF ANY KIND, THE ODDS
OF GETTING CORONAVIRUS AND DYING
ARE SLIM TO NONE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE NO SYMPTOMS,
SOME HAVE MILD SYMPTOMS, SOME
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE IT IS THE FLU
OR RESPIRATORY FLU.
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL FOR THOSE
PEOPLE THAT ARE SICK AND IF YOU
DO KNOW PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK YOU
HAVE TO KEEP A DISTANCE.
LOOK OUT FOR YOUR FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS.
BASIC, SIMPLE THINGS WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
IN THE COMING DAYS AND WEEKS, AS
MORE AMERICANS GET TESTED EXPECT
THAT SHARP RISE.
IT WILL BE CONFIRMED, DON’T
PANIC.
ULTIMATELY, WE BELIEVE IT WILL
LEVEL OFF AND WE WILL BEGIN A